well I mean the results are obvious of
you know can easily be predicted which
is a huge spike in the price any kind of
an oil interruption that is of a major
scale would have an immediate impact on
price and maybe a doubling or even could
potentially even a tripling depending on
how long it lasted weather events are
obviously one hurricane in the gulf of
mexico we've seen with Hurricane Katrina
what happened there the it's called the
loopt Louisiana offshore operating pipe
pipe line or something that's big oil
receiving terminal offshore in the gulf
of mexico that receives a lot of foreign
oil tankers if that were to be hit or
damaged by and damaged by a hurricane
that would have a huge impact tornadoes
on on a major refinery the baytown
refinery in texas is operated by exxon
mobil is the biggest refinery in the
u.s. 500,000 barrels a day if it were
hit by a tornado or a hurricane that
would have a huge impact so i could name
you a whole bunch coo in nigeria coo and
venezuela a coup in saudi arabia
terrorist attack on ab cake the big
Saudi gas oil separation plant that
provides about eight or nine percent of
global oil production yeah I could give
you a long list